well I'm here in accrington in the
Northwest to see leveling up in Action
Now what's leveling up about it's about
investing in local communities so that
we can create jobs Drive growth and make
sure that people feel enormous pride in
the places that they call home today
we've announced new funding coming on
top of what we've already announced
meaning that we've spent almost 4
billion pounds in 200 different
communities across the country including
dozens here in the north west people
have talked about investing in places
like this for years but it's this
government that's delivering it how can
you justify spending 19 million pounds
in your own constituency on catrick
Garrison when other areas partly
Liverpool for example aren't getting any
money well actually if you look at the
overall funding in the leveling up funds
that we've done about two-thirds of all
that funding has gone to the most
deprived part of our country and with
regard to cataract Garrison the thing
you need to know is that's home to our
largest army base and it's home to
actually thousands of serving Personnel
who are often away from their own family
serving our country it's important that
they have access to a Town Center that's
providing the amenities that they need
that's what that funding is going to
deliver I'm really grateful to all our
Armed Forces Personnel for the
incredible job that they do and I'm
delighted that this investment will
support them the majority of the funding
is going to areas that have got
conservative MPS is this pork barrel
politics actually two-thirds of all the
leveling up funding is going to the most
deprived parts of our country I'm here
in accrington I'm just off to Morecambe
I'm traveling across the north today for
example what we're doing is investing in
local communities across the country
leveling up is about making sure people
feel pride in the places they call home
it's about driving jobs and investment
that's what we're doing and I'm pleased
that we can make these announcements
today and it's all part of our plan that
I set out at the beginning of this year
when I said to the country that we were
going to focus on their priorities half
inflation grow the economy reduce debt
cut waiting list and stop the boats
that's what we're getting on and
delivering more money going to London
and the southeast than in the north is
this because you think that you're
hedging your electoral bets that really
you need to shore up the south of
England and give up on the North we're
investing hundreds of millions of pounds
across the North in dozens of projects
I'm here talking to you from accrington
I'm just off to more come after this
then I'm over to the Northeast and the
thing you need to know actually if you
look at the funding and you compare it
to the number of people that live in
each region the region that has done the
best in the amount of funding per person
is the north it's actually that's where
we are today that's why we're here
talking to you in accrington Market
these are the places that are benefiting
from the funding we're delivering on
what we said we're investing in local
communities this is leveling up in
action